welcome to today's webinar titled
improved methods for crispr hdr research
using alt-r modified donors and alt-r
hdr enhancer v2
this webinar is part of the fourth
annual crispr virtual event
i am antonina salcido of labyrinths and
i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
idt
for more information about idt please go
to
www.idtdna.com forward slash crispr
now let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find this live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you will notice that the speaker has
provided a survey located to the right
of the abstract this survey will be
available during both the live session
and the on demand period
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker jessica
woodley research scientist at the
molecular genetics research group at idt
for a complete biography on our seeker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
jessica you may now begin your
presentation
hello uh my name is jessica whibley and
i'm a research scientist in the crispr r
d group at idt
and today i'll be walking you through
some of the work that we've been doing
to improve and streamline the hdr design
process and some of our newer products
designed to improve hdr rates including
our modified donors
and small molecule enhancers such as our
newly released altar hdr enhancer v2
all right so here's our obligatory uh
dna repaired pathway slide
so after you've used your crisper
reagents
beverage cas9 or cast vulva
to generate your double stranded break
uh if note a donor template is provided
uh that double stranded break will be
repaired through the non-homologous end
joining pathway and so this predominant
pathway uh results in the formation of
imprecise indels and as i'm sure most of
you are aware that's very useful for
generating knockouts and genomic screens
however if we provide a
dna template
with our desired edits
for short edits you can use a single
stranded oligos or for larger edits you
can use long single stranded or double
stranded dna
you can then generate specific mutations
or insertions through the hdr or
homology directed repair pathway
and
this is useful for changing alleles
either to mimic or correct a disease or
for generating gene fusions and as i'm
sure most of you are aware
hdr rates can be challenging in certain
systems
and so with that in mind we set out
to
look for ways that we could improve hdr
efficiency and so the first portion of
my talk will be focusing on
improvements through the design of the
donor template
and
that also incorporates selection of
appropriate
crispr reagents so looking for high
activity guides
and then also looking at how that uh
cleavage site of the cast 9 guide
is placed relative to your desired edit
and also looking into with your donor
templates the use of optimal blocking
mutations to prevent cas9 recutting
after hdr and then also looking at
optimal homology arm length
the second portion of my talk will focus
on how using improved hdr agents can
enhance uh hdr
and so
uh i'll have a portion of my talk that
focuses on using small molecules to
modulate repair pathways
and then a section looking at our
current uh and future
products
where we've added modifications into
repair templates for improved stability
and better hdr
and we're very excited to talk about
those
all right so uh we do have a full
workflow for uh crispr research at idt
going all the way from experimental
design through analysis
uh and i'm not gonna cover all of this
uh but
uh in my talk i will be
discussing our hdr design tool which has
a friendly ui and
provides optimal
donor templates
based on empirically defined design
rules
and that is fully integrated with our
cas9 guide rna design tool as well
we also have a full suite of
guide rnas and crispr proteins available
i won't be focusing specifically on
those but
for our hdr reagents i will be covering
our donor templates
and so
for
short edits we have our altar hdr donor
oligos that are available up to 200
bases
and those are modified
single-stranded oligos based on our
ultramark chemistry
the
for longer
templates we offer currently our megamer
long single-stranded dnas up to 2000
bases
but we are very excited uh that we'll be
releasing our altar hdr donor blocks
which are modified linear double
stranded dnas that are up to 3000 base
pairs
and those modifications are designed to
increase hdr and also reduce
potential off-target effects
and so those will be available
later this year or early next year
and the final product that i'll be
highlighting is our
small molecule
hdr enhancers um
and actually that should be updated our
version two just launched this month um
all right so now getting into the data
the first step in designing any hdr
experiment
is guide selection and there are three
big factors to consider for that
the first is the position of the
cleavage site
generally you want to be
as close
to the hdr insertion as possible
the second point is guide efficiency and
generally you need to have high
efficiency to mediate high levels of hdr
and if you
are using a poor efficiency guide that's
really going to
impact negatively
your potential hdr rate
and the last factor to keep in mind is
the risk for off-target effects
and so we recommend using a guide with a
good specificity score um either using
our guide rna tool or others available
to predict off targets
and that'll just help reduce any
potential off-target activity
and so in the next couple slides uh
i'll be
uh showing a case study to highlight the
importance of this second point looking
for guide efficiency
um and actually confirming your guide
efficiency prior to hdr experiments so
in this
experiment we are targeting a six base
pair insert
to the gap dh gene uh right before the
stop codon
and so we're considering a number of
factors here again
the position of that cleavage site
relative to the hdr edit
shown here are
a number of guides that cut between 2 to
14 base pairs away we did test further
out as well
and then
the other factor that we're considering
here is guide efficiency
and so if we look at the actual hdr
rates for a number of these guides
targeting this locus what we found is
that the two closest guides
here that cut two and five base pairs
away
actually turned out to have very poor
total editing which you can see here
measured by t7e1
and so because of that low overall
editing efficiency with these two guides
you can see that the hdr rates are
correspondingly
limited
and actually the best guide that we
found to work at this site
it cuts six-pace pairs downstream
from our target insert site and you can
see we can get hdr rates uh up to 50
percent as measured by equal r1's uh
cleavage
uh
and what we found surprising is actually
the second best guide uh cuts 14 base
pairs away
upstream
and again that's a high efficiency guide
and so we were able to get higher rates
of hdr
so this is an extreme case where the
editing rates are lower but it does
highlight an important
step of confirming your editing
efficiency with your guides prior to hdr
experiments
all right so the introduction of
blocking mutations into the hdr donor is
particularly useful when the hdr edit
does not disrupt caslin recognition and
so for building out our altar hdr design
tool we set out to build a empirically
defined rule set
to base our recommendations on and so
i'm highlighting here a sample
experiment from that testing
and so for this experiment we were
introducing a snip adjacent to the pam
where the hdr event is susceptible to
further editing by cast9
and then we assessed whether a single
blocking mutation
was sufficient to prevent cast 9
recutting and give us perfect hdr
and
to do that we mutated each position
within the pam and within the guide seed
region to every other possible base
and as you can see we tested this in
two cell lines and at two different
sites and the results here are plotted
as a heat map
and what we found is that uh introducing
blocking mutations within the g
positions of the pam or neither the
three prime end of the guide
uh brought our hdr rates
up from around one percent as a baseline
up to 10 to 20 hdr
and we also found that no base was
universally preferred over others
and as i indicated we did do further
testing looking at combinations of
mutations as well
but that all was built into the
rule set for our design tool and up in
the upper right you can see after
developing this rule set we then did
check
the tools model for
blocking mutations with a variety of
edits
including various size insertions at
different sites as well as snips and
deletions
and aside from one data point
you can see that the hdr8 benefited from
the addition of these silent mutations
from our design tool
all right so now on the next few slides
i'll be running through the design
process with our hdr design tool
and on this first menu you'll be
selecting your target
and there is a very flexible input
format
that includes either selecting a gene or
genomic coordinates for
common genomes including human mouse
rats c elegans and zebrafish
and if you're using one of these common
genomes it does allow you to select an
ncbi transcript
and so that will automatically upload
coding information
uh for incorporating silent mutations in
the subsequent menus
if you're working in other species or
using batch designs we also offer a
fafsa input
and further down on the menu you can
also enter in the edit location
if you know exactly where you want to do
your edit
and
you can enter in guide information as
well if you've already confirmed those
elements
otherwise they can be selected on the
interactive interface later
all right uh so on the second menu here
uh after you've picked your targets um
you can then select your specific hdr
edit
and so if you entered in uh the
coordinates for your hdr edit it will
automatically zoom in otherwise you can
use these blue sliders here
to select the uh specific location that
you want to introduce a sequence
or a mutation
and so
uh if you want to generate a snip or a
deletion you can select
the bases that you want to edit
and then enter in the replacement down
below here on the mutation bar
otherwise you can
put
push these two sliders together
and
any sequence that you enter in the
mutation bar will be entered in
as in uh direct insert
wherever those blue sliders are set
and you can see
on the little map
if you have entered in your ncbi
transcript it does give you the
translation of the gene down below
and above you can see that it is entered
in that hdr edit that we have typed in
additionally you can select
specific homology arm lengths we do have
defaults of 40 for short edits and
200 for larger edits
and down below you can also select
whether you want the tool to
automatically incorporate blocking
mutations
all right
so this is what the design output looks
like from the tool and so in this
particular example uh we're showing two
different outputs
on the top you can see it is the output
without any blocking mutations
incorporated
and so you can see the guide rna that
we've selected is shown
down below as well as the cut site is
indicated
uh the hdr edit is highlighted in
green
and you can see the translations down
below so we can confirm that's correct
as well
and in the second panel down below you
can see
uh
indicated where those two specific
blocking mutations are
and on the right we do have
some hdr data here
looking for that
perfect hdr in dark blue
and you can see that those silent
mutations do indeed increase the hdr
rate
and this tool is fully integrated with
our
web ordering so it will allow you to
order the paired guide rna and the
hdr template as well
all right uh so moving beyond our hdr
design tool uh unfortunately you may run
into a situation
where guide availability is limited
in your sequence of interest
and as most of you are likely aware hdr
efficiency does really drop off after
you get beyond uh 10 or 15 base pairs
away from the hdr edit
and cut site
and so an example of that is just shown
here where we've walked uh the hdr
insert
position uh for a six space insert
um
and so we asked uh how can we improve
the hdr rates
in these cases where you're cutting uh
over uh 15 base pairs away from the cut
site
and so one important factor that we have
found with these types of edits
is strand selection
and so when you're using a single
stranded oligo
like in these experiments
we have typically found
that
hdr edits that are near the cut site
don't have any generalized
strand preference so we empirically
determine
whether the non-targeting or targeting
strand would be preferred
however
in this case we're introducing
again a six base insert
20 base pairs pam distal or pam proximal
relative to our guide sequence
and in these cases uh for these two
sites tested here that were pulled from
a larger testing set for simplicity you
can see that
pam distal edits have a very strong
preference for the non-targeting strand
uh
while the edits that are placed paint
proximal have a very strong preference
for the targeting strand
so if you're using single stranded
oligos
and editing far away from your cas9
cleavage site this is an important
factor to keep in mind
the
we then further investigated whether or
not there were any preferences for
the placement of silent blocking
mutations for these types of hdr edits
and so again
in this experiment we were
inserting a six base sequence
in this case 25 base pairs away from the
cup site
and looking at it at that
with both pam distal edits uh and with
pam proximal edits
and then we tested donors that either
had no further mutation
included a pain mutation or included a
repair track mutation and so
we just evenly spaced out
snips between the cut site and the
hdr insert
and so what we found if we look at the
preferred strand in both of these cases
is that
mutations that are placed on the same
side of the double-stranded break as the
hdr edit were preferred
and so that particularly comes into play
with that pam distal edit
so if we look at these
hdr8 by ngs you can see that we don't
have any perfect hdr
when no extra mutation is
incorporated the pam mutation does bring
that up to about four percent uh on the
pam distal side
um at the three low side we tested this
at
um
however if we then included those repair
track mutations uh where those snips
were placed on the same side of the
double strand of break as our hdr edit
you can see we're bringing that up to
about 13
in the case of the pam proximal
mutations
there wasn't any really further benefit
to the repair track mutations over the
pam mutation since that's all on the
same side of the double stranded break
as the hdr edit
all right
so now moving on beyond the improved
designs
the next portion of the talk will focus
on improved reagents
and so we'll start out first
discussing our small molecules to
modulate repair pathways
and then focus in on the
modified
donor oligos and donor blocks
for improved hdr
so
for the small molecule enhancers
um
our altar hdr enhancer v2 has really
been a game-changing improvement for us
for hdr rates
so after launching our original hdr
enhancer
which is shown here in light orange
which gives about a four-fold increase
in hdr in this experiment
we found that
it was
better than the majority of the
compounds that were published in the
literature and you can show or see some
of our screening results here
and what we found when we looked at
compounds from the literature is that
the majority of them really didn't have
a strong impact on our hdr rates
however after we launched our original
hdr enhancer we did continue evaluating
new compounds
and our
best new solution
that offers
improved hdr is shown here in dark
orange which is our recently launched
altar hdr enhancer v2
and you can
see here that we're getting a cherries
up to eighty percent for this six space
insert in jerket cells
and in addition to
better hdr efficiency uh the v2 enhancer
can also be delivered at a lower dose
and so that allows for better style
viability as well
okay
and on this slide i'm just showing
various
uh small edits that we've made uh in
varying human cell lines as well as
varying milestone lines
and you can see across the board that we
get increased hdr
when using either our
version one or version two enhancers uh
but that the
version two offers the best hdr around
um
and uh i don't have the data shown here
uh but we've also shown that it works
well for improving caswell by hdr as
well
all right so now moving into modified
templates
for
repair template sequences that are less
than 200 bases
our hdr design tool will automatically
design ultra hdr donor oligos
and so
again these
short oligos are based on our top
quality altimeters
and these include additional
modifications that help boost hdr and so
this modification pattern was
the result of extensive testing
with oligos to identify a top
modification pattern to improve hdrs and
so here you can see um
is a summary of our testing
and so this was tested at multiple sites
and in multiple human and male cell
lines and you can see
we get about a seven-fold improvement
on average over an unmodified uh oligo
and we're also highlighting here
um that phosphorothyroid modified donors
which have been published in the
literature give about a four-fold uh
increase in hdr relative to the
unmodified so
the increased stability that you get
in cells
with the donor also is beneficial for
improved hdr as
well and on the slide is just a little
bit more
direct comparison
at individual sites
in our human jerk at cell line and in
the mouse cell line h3612j
and again this is a
short six-space insert that's being
generated in each of these cases
and you can see
if we look at the unmodified donor we're
starting at about one to two percent
hdr in these challenging systems
we do get a decent boost to the hdra
when using those phosphorothyroid
modified donors but we get much better
hdr with the altar modified
donor all logos as well
all right now finally for this section
i do want to highlight that the combined
use of the altar hdr donor oligos and
the altar hdr enhancer v2 offers an
improved solution for generating those
small hdr edits particularly when you're
in a challenging system and starting off
at one or two percent hdr
and so
uh
just starting with our baseline of
unmodified untreated uh
uh reagents you can see in the dark blue
that we're starting between one to ten
percent hdr
um
and if we add the
hdr enhancer v2 we do get a nice uh
boost to the hdr rates and as we add
further modifications to the donors you
can see again we're getting a nice boost
to the hdr rates
uh and with our combined approach you
can see we're getting above 40 percent
uh hdr in all of these cases
all right
so now shifting gears to discuss larger
napkins
and go over some work from
the development of one of our upcoming
products
when we considered potential repair
templates for larger napkins
one of the easiest to produce is plasmid
dna
however we found
in our testing that the hdr efficiency
is limited when using plasmid
and that's because it can have higher
toxicity with your cells which
eliminates or limits the effective dose
that you can deliver
and so for
many years now we've offered our mega
mer long single stranded dna product
and this works well for hdr
and
is pretty well tolerated by cells
however it is a fairly complicated
manufacturing process and so
it does have a higher cost and
turnaround time
and so this has
generally worked well for
my micro injection work uh the yields
that are generated are sufficient for
that
however it's not really a cost of
effective a cost effective solution for
cell work
and so we started looking into
alternatives and turned to linear
double-stranded dna
and generally linear double-stranded dna
we found does work well for hdr
and has similar toxicity
to cells
as long single-stranded dna
however its main drawback is the risk of
off target integration which i'll get
into on the next slide
and so
we decided based on reports in the
literature to see if we could
incorporate modifications into the
linear double-stranded dna
to help mitigate this risk and promote
hdr
all right
so when we're
referring to this off-target risk
what that really comes down to is
homology independent integration with
the linear double-stranded dna
and so uh after the double-stranded dna
is uh generated ideally when you
introduce your long template
you'll get a nice clean repair through
hdr
however the linear double-stranded dna
ends can similarly be recognized by the
nhj repair machinery and so you can get
insertion through the nhj pathway
and so if you're looking at your
ontarget site that can result in the
duplication of one or both of your
homology arms
and this can similarly happen
at any endogenous double-stranded dna
breaks
or cast 9 off target sites
and so the on target site isn't as much
of a concern since you can screen out
those edits fairly easily
however those
integration into any off target sites is
a concern
all right so we set out to screen a wide
variety of modifications
for the ability to prevent that off
target
integration and so here i'm showing you
a sample of that screening results
so generally our system involved
introducing modifications into a short
double-stranded dna donor
in this case uh inserting a 42 base pair
insert
that contained an ecor1 restriction site
we would then deliver this donor with a
cas9 that was complex with either the
on-target guide rna
or a guide rna targeting another locus
which gave us an opportunity to
artificially look at
off-target double-stranded dna breaks so
after editing we would then amplify up
these target sites
and assess insertion using equal or one
digestion and then based on the sizes of
the digestion products we could
determine whether it was hdr
or a blunt insertion
and so in general we selected
modifications such as g
shown here where we got an increase in
the hdr rates
as well as a decrease in the blunt
insertion rates
at both the on and off target
sites
all right so after we had done all of
our screening
we then set out to further confirm them
in additional cell lines and at
additional sites and a summary of our
results is shown here
and so when we were testing with these
shorter sequences we found that our top
modification pattern
labeled here as the altar
mod
offered improved
ratios of hdr to blunt insertion at the
on target site
up to four fold
alright so once we had identified our
modification
we then set out to look at how it
behaved with large knock-ins relative to
alternative templates and so here we're
comparing
long single-stranded dna
either the targeting or non-targeting
strands
relative to an unmodified
double-stranded dna or our altar
modified double stranded dna and you can
see
when we target a gfp insert three
different loci
in two different cell lines
you can see our baseline hdra with the
long single stranded dnas
was
less than 5
if we delivered an equal molar dose of
the unmodified double stranded dna you
can see that gets us up to about 10
um
and
if we then used our altar modified
double stranded dna that brought us up
to about 15 hdr so we're seeing improved
rates um
and if we then introduced our alter hdr
enhancer v2 what we found uh
was very pleasing that the treatment of
the v2 enhancer works very well with
linear double stranded dna
and so you can see that the v2 brings
the single stranded dna templates up to
10 to 20
hdr
uh however
we get up to 50 to 70 percent
hdr with the
v2 enhancer and the hdr donor blocks
and if we use long-range sequencing to
further dig into the editing what we can
actually see is that the long
single-stranded dna templates uh result
in partial integration
uh where the
five-prime junction uh relative to the
donor template
has these deletions occurring
and we do not see that with the
double-stranded dna template
all right
on this slide uh we're looking further
into that uh off target risk and so
again we have four different uh
templates for gfp nokians
um
and we're introducing that with a mock
off target double stranded break
with an rnp targeting the servancy one
locus
and so what we see is
when we deliver the unmodified templates
with this off-target
rnt we get up to
about 23
insertion at this off target site
if we add our modification in
uh we can bring that down to about eight
percent uh insertion
and what's nice is if we further treat
with this uh altar hdr enhancer v2 which
should modulate the repair pathways we
can actually bring this down to about
uh background detection levels
uh and now this is a worst case scenario
uh where the off-target double-stranded
dna break is being generated near uh 100
percent efficiency so i wouldn't expect
to see this high of levels with typical
cas9 off targets
all right uh so the last couple
experiments that i want to highlight
here are looking at improved designs
with the altar hdr donor blocks
uh so on this first slide we're looking
at the impact homology arm length with
varying size inserts uh and so we have
uh insertion sizes ranging from 120 base
pairs up to 2 kb
targeting different sites
and tested homology arm lengths
from 40 up to 300 base pairs for the
shorter sizes and then 40 up to 500 base
pairs for the longer inserts
and these were delivered as both equal
molar doses
where the differences are a little bit
more exaggerated as well as equal mass
and we actually looked at equal mass a
little bit
more uh since we found that cells are
limited on the total mass that can be
delivered before uh you're significantly
impacting cell viability
uh and so you can actually
increase the hdr rates a little bit more
for those shorter uh homology arms
but overall what you can see is that
the hdr8 begins plateauing around 100 to
200 base pairs
um
for the homology arm length for the
shorter inserts uh and then it begins
plateauing around 200 to 300 base pairs
for the longer
inserts
and so generally we recommend starting
out at 200 base pairs
as a default starting
point for your homology arm lengths
but this may vary by cell type or system
all right and so the last little bit of
data i have here is looking at
improvements uh in the design of
blocking mutations with larger inserts
this is very similar to the results that
we
observed with our single stranded algos
where if you're generating a 300 base
pair insert um
uh 20 base pairs upstream or downstream
of your cut site
um generally we found that
uh including blocking mutations that are
on the same side of your double-stranded
break as your insert uh is actually the
best design and so again with the pam
distal design uh we recommend uh using
those track mutations
um
and then with the pan distal mutation or
the pan proximal mutations excuse me
um a pain mutation alone is sufficient
all right uh so
overall we do recommend
careful consideration
of your donor template design
and the selection of your guide rna to
improve your hdr rates
from that aspect and our altar hdr
design tool
is an easy way to generate those
blocking mutations and look for
potential guide rnas
and we also recommend the use of our
ultra hdr enhancer v2 that just launched
this month
and that's been a game-changing way to
improve our hdr rates
and then finally the inclusion of
modifications in your donor templates
does allow you to stabilize those donors
and cells and promote your
hdr rates
so
in conclusion
i do want to
acknowledge our team
including our full
crispr r d group as well as our
bioinformatics scientists that support
us in all of our endeavors
our products and tools can be found on
the hdr and crispr websites
listed here i'm happy to take any
questions
and any additional inquiries can be sent
to our crispr idt dna.com email
all right